it's behind these bars at this Belgian
prison that Frank fund and laken has
been locked up for almost 30 years a
convicted rapist and murderer wants
doctors to end his life he says he can't
control his sexual urges and doesn't
want to leave prison because there's a
risk he'll strike again there are no
viable treatment options left for him he
says euthanasia dr dominique lawson all
disputes these arguments at this clinic
in brussels he's assisted many patients
wishing to die and he says euthanasia
must always remain a last resort you see
suply better than no because she be I'm
very surprised that all other treatment
paths for a sexual criminal have
suddenly run out she beat me I look
official visit opal if that is the case
you have to ask the question if there
were adequate provisions here to ensure
the right healing dispose ed Keystone
bosque de canto poverty she's devoted
swanepoel Cody give his funk fund and
laken incurably ill or the product of a
broken penal system Belgium's prisons
have long been criticized in particular
by the European Court of Human Rights it
says prisoners endure appalling
conditions such as little space and
insufficient treatment options fund and
laken had asked to move to a prison in
the Netherlands but his request was
turned down politician Christine de
freno supports euthanasia in principle
but she says many criminals are being
pressed to take that path
kudla problematic design a kiss with a
problem is people here in Belgium who
should be receiving treatment and
special centers are sitting in prison
because there's insufficient space in
the treatment centers the law isn't here
to empty our prisons vdd presume this
debate is too late for Franklin and
bacon his assisted suicide will likely
take place soon